who is your fairy godmother in the
industry in the industry um i feel like
maybe like like taylor swift would be
like my
my my fabulous godmother
[Music]
i started out
and i was like a teenager when i met her
like 18 or something and
she always just gave me great advice was
kind of
was just always really supportive of me
and really like nurturing and sweet um
so in the industry i would i would say
her yeah do we have a date tonight or
cinderella hitting the ball solo i'm
hitting the ball solo that's right tell
me about the dress you look amazing i'm
wearing oscar de la renta
um and it's so beautiful um it's got
this little oh
you know little hairy leg
action um
keeping it grounded thank you cinderella
for getting to shave um but yeah i feel
i feel really pretty and i'm really
excited about tonight well do you feel
like a movie star because you're a movie
star now you're that's your name up
there and
i mean what i love is that kay for
example your wonderful director keeps
saying that you kind of are this
incredible cinderella story you've
worked so hard and here you are has it
all sunk in yet do you understand that
you are the lead in this incredible
feature movie i mean
it's amazing i think that it's
definitely not sunken
but i really feel you know i feel like
about you know keeping it grounded feel
really grounded surrounded by these
amazing people billy porter um edina uh
nick like they're all just incredible
people and
we had so much fun making this together
so
i really like i feel like usually i
would feel nervous doing something like
this and i
not the movie i mean the premiere i was
nervous during the movie uh but i'm i'm
not right now it just feels really
celebratory uh we
you know we had a lot of obstacles
making this film we made in the middle
of covid and didn't know what was what
was happening cinderella you don't need
to go to the ball please stepmother i
spent weeks making this dress my future
depends on it how did you prepare for
this being your your acting debut and
it's so much did you take acting lessons
what'd you do i did i mean i've been
taking acting lessons for
a while now like not like all the time
but i have this amazing acting coach
he's here tonight his name is anthony
meindel um and so we took a lot of
a lot of classes together so i think
that prepared me a lot but i think it's
all about being present having fun and
not taking yourself too seriously as
hard as that can be sometimes don't
shave those legs i won't
i'll never shave never shave again
[Music]
you